Guten Morgen, Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Wie sieht es denn aus? Haben wir unsere mediale Schlachtordnung bereit?
Ja, wir haben die mediale Schlachtordnung vorbereitet für die heutige Ausgabe des Logbuches Netzpolitik, dem historischen Podcast über das Web 2.0.
Ja, das ja demnächst Geschichte sein könnte.
Sein wird.
Es ist ganz klar, die Revolution ist vorbei. Die Frage ist nur, wie groß das digitale Blut vergesen bis dahin ausgefallen sein wird.
Ja, was für ein Tag. Just einen Tag hier vor Aufnahme unserer mittlerweile zwölften Ausgabe von Logbuch Netzpolitik sitzen Linus und ich hier und können sich fast nicht mehr halten vor Lachen, weil es einfach so absurd ist, was ein Mensch namens Ansgar Heveling, seines Zeichens Mitglied des Deutschen Bundestages, auch Mitglied der Internet-Enquete.
Ja, das ist eigentlich der traurige Teil dieser Sache.
Und auch Sitznachbar von Herrn Groni, wenn ich das richtig gehört habe.
Ist das so? Ich habe die Sitzordnung bei der Enquete nicht im Kopf.
Mir wurde so berichtet, dass er...
Also die würden auf jeden Fall richtungsmäßig, sollten die eigentlich nebeneinander sitzen. Das ist schon richtig.
Ja, also die meisten von euch werden es vielleicht schon mitbekommen haben, weil es war unschwer zu verpassen. Zumindest wenn man so zu den Twitter-Junkies gehört. Aber da ja laut Herrn Heveling das Web 2.0 bald Geschichte sein wird, denke ich mal ist es auch erforderlich, dass man hier den ruinenhaften Stümpfen unserer Gesellschaft, die er da proklamiert hat, da auch mal Einblick gibt in solche Ereignisse. Also er hat da ein Pamphlet abgelassen in Form eines sogenannten Gastkommentars im Handelsblatt. Wobei lustig fand ich, dass es zunächst einmal für die Print-Ausgabe gedacht war, sich dann allerdings die Redaktion des Handelsblattes entschlossen hat, das auch schnellstens ins Netz zu stellen, weil das einfach so, ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau welches Adjektiv da verwendet wurde, aber sie fanden es wohl so...
Passend?
Nee, nee, nee, nee, absurd oder irgendein... ja abfällige Bezeichnung, die ich jetzt nicht mehr ganz erinnere. Also sie fanden es einfach so strange. Da mussten sie, dass das irgendwie auch ins Internet gehörte. Wobei die allerersten Nachrichtenmeldungen zu den Heveling gingen, das waren ja auch Scans der Print-Ausgabe. Also das war so das erste, was ich gesehen habe. Also es war eh im Netz und dann war es nur noch eine Frage der Zeit, bis man es dann eben auch direkt klingen konnte.
Ich denke, das Handelsblatt wollte die Werbereinnahmen davon haben, also die Klicks, die wir gestern bekommen haben. Also ich würde mich nicht wundern, wenn der jetzt schon einen Vertrag da hat für eine wöchentliche Kolumne.
Genau, also bevor wir wieder zu sehr aus der Insider-Perspektive reden, also Heveling hat diesen Gastkommentar gemacht und es handelt sich wirklich um ein zweiseitiges Pamphlet, wenn man das ausdruckt, wo man sich wirklich nur noch an den Kopf fasst und sich einfach fragt, was diesen Herren da reitet. Unter dem Titel Netzgemeinde, ihr werdet den Kampf verlieren, Ausrufezeichen. Fügt er also hier wirklich in einem Sprachgewitter, Aphorismen da aneinander, wo man sich wirklich, wo man einfach gar nicht mehr weiß, wie dieser Mensch eigentlich, also ob das jetzt wirklich eine Trollerei ist. Der erste Eindruck, den ich hatte, ist, das kann auch nicht sein Ernst sein. So ein Text, das kann niemand, der irgendwie halbwegs sich in dem Feld bewegt, das tut er ja schreiben, das kann einfach nur eine Persiflage, eine Glosse, eine Überzeichnung sein, das ist am Ende noch gehackt und von ganz jemand anderem, aber am Ende hat sich das halt wirklich herausgestellt, dass es alles wahr ist.
Ja, und das ist auch nicht die Offenbarung eines einsamen Apokalyptikers, es ist die Perspektive eines geschichtsbewussten Politikers. Das weiß er ja zu betonen. Ja, was schreibt denn der gute Mann? Also er bezieht sich quasi, er sagt so, dass das Web 2.0 ist, will quasi die französische Revolution rückgängig machen, als nämlich 1789 der Citoyenne geboren wurde, als quasi Freiheit, Demokratie und Eigentum. Ich dachte immer eigentlich, dass Liberté, Egalité, Fraternité auf den Frontstücken stand.
Aber da müssen wir uns geirrt haben. Vielleicht ist das einfach nur schlecht übersetzt worden und tatsächlich bedeutet das Eigentum.
Genau, also da offensichtlich katastrophaler Übersetzungsfehler der Werte der französischen Revolution, den er da aufgedeckt hat.
Und das hat über 300 Jahre gehalten.
Ja, genau, aber er ist ja geschichtsbewusster Politiker und klärt darüber auf, dass jetzt also mit digitalem Totalitarismus von den digitalen Maoisten gegen die französische Revolution angegangen werden soll. Und wenn Google und Wikipedia irgendwie einen Zensurwalken davor machen oder die Seite abschalten, dann sollte man Goethe zitieren, die Bibel oder auch Marx aus einem gebundenen Buch. Das ist also die Maßnahme, wie sich jetzt die Bürger erheben sollen. Man soll sich irgendwie nichts von der digitalen Avantgarde erzählen lassen. Piraten sind der schlechteste Ratgeber, was das Beste für die Masche Mensch sei.
Masse.
Ja, Narzissmus und Nerzissmus sind Zwillinge, wir brauchen einen Citoyen und so. Also vor allem ist, was wirklich schwierig an diesem Artikel ist, was will der? Also offensichtlich ist es sein Thema ist offensichtlich geistiges Eigentum. Diese Argumentation, dass das geistiges Eigentum eine Errungenschaft der Aufklärung ist, oder der der französischen Revolution ist auch gar nicht so neu. Die habe ich auch in ähnlicher Form von Sascha Lobo beim A2N.
Also All Together Now, diese Alternativveranstaltung zum Thema Musik und Musikindustrie und die Popcom.
Genau, wo viel mit Netzbezug über neue Modelle der Vermarktung nachgedacht werden soll. Da hatte er mal ein Streitgespräch mit dem Marcel Weiss und da hat Sascha Lobo ähnlich argumentiert, dass er quasi eine der großen Errungenschaften der letzten Zeit ist, das ist dieses geistige Eigentum, die Möglichkeit mit Kunst und der sonstigen Sachen Geld zu verdienen. Insofern ist das gar nicht so neu. Ist nur hier ein bisschen sehr absurd dargestellt. Also offensichtlich geht es irgendwie so um Sopa und Pieper und wahrscheinlich dann auch um ACTA. Aber ansonsten ist das nach wie vor so ein bisschen ungleich. Also es ist fast tragisch.
Gehen wir mal davon aus, dass hier wirklich der CDU-Politiker spricht, der er ist. Und ohne das jetzt vielleicht zu sehr für die gesamte CSU gleich stehen lassen zu wollen, weil da gab es auch genug Rückmeldungen von Leuten, die einfach mit dem Kopf geschüttet haben, so aus dem sogenannten netzpolitischen Bereich der CDU. Auch sowas gibt es. Und die, jetzt habe ich mir mein klingendes Telefon, hat mich jetzt gerade verwirrt. Worauf beziehe ich mich jetzt? Wenn er das wirklich so denkt, dann frage ich mich, ob das jetzt hier so ein Hilferuf ist, so ein Verzweiflungsruf, so Holla, diese Netzgemeinde oder was auch immer er hier direkt ansprechen möchte. Eigentlich, das überrollt uns, wir kommen damit nicht klar. Und dann so affirmativ geht er dann so in die Öffentlichkeit, vergisst es. Das wird nicht klappen. Das erinnert mich so ein bisschen an Gaddafi, der dann so wirklich mit dem Regenschirm in der Hand steht, im Bombenhagel und so weiter. Unsere Feinde werden uns einfach niemals über Mannen und Freunde steht nur zusammen. Und das wird alles nicht stimmen. Das ist auch alles nur eine totale Verschwörung. So kommt mir das irgendwie vor.
Auch so von den Stilmitteln ist das nämlich sehr komisch, dass er, also er fängt halt an so, ja, ja, verkackt so, ne. Und dann fängt er aber an und hat die ganze Zeit so, Bürger geht auf die Barrikaden, zitiert Goethe.
Und Marx. Also ich meine, dass ein CDU-Politiker jetzt auf einmal auch noch auffordert, Marx zu lesen.
Ja komm. Also jetzt haben wir noch die Zeit diesem Treiben, einen Einhalt zu gebieten. Also er wechselt so von dieser, ihr habt verkackt, zu Leute, macht bitte mit, die machen hier Totalitarismus und so. Völlig wirr. Also was denke ich mal das Erschreckendste daran ist, also wenn man diesen Text liest, wie gesagt, schon allein von der Wahl der Stil, von der Argumentation her, ist er wie gesagt sehr wirr. Aber man wundert sich ja schon, wieso ist dieser Mensch in der Enquete-Kommission Internet und Digitale Gesellschaft? Ja, also das ist ja schon interessant. Also die wurde ja vom Bundestag irgendwie da besetzt oder einberufen, weil sie sehen, dass das ein sehr wichtiges politisches Thema ist, wo sich irgendwie die Gesellschaft verändert. Und dann sagt der Bundestag, hier steht irgendwie was an, da brauchen wir eine Enquete-Kommission. Enquete-Kommissionen gibt es ansonsten irgendwie vielleicht auch mal zu den Herausforderungen in der Bildungspolitik. Gab es, glaube ich, mal eine Enquete und so, aber es sind oder Naturschutz und solche Sachen. Zu solchen Themen werden dann Enquete-Kommissionen einberufen, wo man sagt, jetzt müssen wir wirklich mal die ganzen Leute hier an einen Tisch setzen. Wir brauchen Experten, die wir da befragen. Wir müssen eine umfassende Meinung zu einem Thema bilden. Und dass da jemand zwei Jahre drin sitzt, und die Enquete müsste jetzt zwei Jahre laufen. Dass da jemand zwei Jahre drin sitzt und dann sich mit so einem Artikel im Handelsblatt... der...
Ja, ich meine, da sieht man mal, was die eigentliche Intention war. Also die Intention war nicht da wirklich produktiv mitzumischen, sondern sie haben da irgendwelche Vögel hingesetzt, von denen sie wussten, dass sie selbst, wenn die nachvollziehbarsten Argumente auf dem Tisch legen, dass sie einfach trotzdem noch dagegen stimmen.
Interessant ist, ich meine, es gibt da ja auch, was weiß ich zum Beispiel, wer ist da noch, von der CDU, nehmen wir mal Thomas Jatzombek. Er hat im Prinzip die gleichen Ansichten.
Wer ist das?
Der ist auch von der CDU da in der Enquete-Kommission. Jatzombek, der ist aus Düsseldorf irgendwie da hin, also Düsseldorf, irgendwie in den Bundestag gekommen. Und, oder warte, jetzt quatsche ich, der rennt doch da in der Enquete-Kommission. Ja, Entschuldigung, es war jetzt nicht unter den ersten Google-Treffern, deswegen, weil ich jetzt kurz nimm es. Der hat, also er hat so ähnliche Ansichten, aber der ist wenigstens in der Lage, die irgendwie argumentativ zu verpacken. Also der hat irgendwie auch mal im Internet gearbeitet. Steht hier, glaube ich, in seiner, irgendwie Unternehmer oder was auch immer.
Im Internet hat er gearbeitet.
Ah, irgendwas mit Internet hat er gearbeitet.
Wahrscheinlich am Internet.
War auch mal im Internet. Und, äh, nee, aber, nein. Mit dem kannst du wenigstens dich unterhalten. Der bringt dann auch haarsträumende Argumente, aber der hat sich mit seinem Thema auseinandergesetzt. Und der ist halt irgendwie für Urheberrecht und so und ist da auch sicherlich bereit, bei anderen Grundrechten Abstriche vielleicht ein bisschen zu machen oder hat da eine andere Sicht drauf. Aber mit dem kannst du dich wenigstens unterhalten. So der kommt zu irgendeiner Veranstaltung hin und dann kannst du mit dem argumentieren. Dann haut der auch vielleicht mal ein paar Plattitüden raus. Aber das kann man ja dann noch als rhetorische Herausforderung sehen. Beim Thomas Zornberg zum Beispiel. Aber irgendwie so ein Ansgar-Heveling. Also wirklich nur von ganz unabhängig davon, was das jetzt inhaltlich da bedeutet. Allein so einen Text zu schreiben, damit disqualifiziert der sich doch eindeutig dafür, irgendwo in so einem Expertengremium, wo Menschen sitzen, die sich mit ihren Themen auseinandersetzen, wo ein gewisser Anspruch herrscht, dass der ohnehin irgendwie ad absurdum geführt wird, dadurch, dass da irgendwie diese politischen Tricks, ja ich meine da, man erinnere sich irgendwie an die Abstimmungen zur Netzneutralität und so, was da schon alles in der Enquete los war. Aber da haben immer wenigstens alle noch versucht, den Schein zu wahren und da irgendwie einen auf informiertes, gesittetes Zusammenkommen zu machen. Und jetzt hast du da so einen.
Ja, also wir wollen jetzt auch nicht so sehr das ausbreiten. Das Thema entwickelt sich ja im Netz ohnehin recht schnell. Es kam dann relativ schnell zu allerlei lustigen Glossen. Und auf Twitter wurde unter dem Hashtag HevelingFacts auch wirklich ein Feuerzauber der Assoziation entfacht. Das ist wirklich großartig.
Auf seiner Webseite wurde kurz darauf dann der Austritt aus der CDU erklärt. Das ist sehr interessant. Ich hab das auch mal so gemacht. Wenn man mal seine eigene Webseite prüfen möchte auf eventuelle Sicherheitslücken, gibt es dann so automatische Tools, die das für einen erledigen. Die kann man natürlich auch mal auf andere Webseiten laufen lassen. Dann kommt man unter anderem zu sehr interessanten Ergebnissen. Deswegen dauerte es eben auch nicht besonders lange, bis diese Seite dann eben etwas anderes zeigt. Es sieht im Moment noch so aus, als würde da noch einer gehen. Naja, dann so klassische Dinge, mal die Webseite irgendwie verändern. Dann gab es schön als Büttenrede wurde das Ganze vertont. Selbstverständlich dann auch mit dem Gestos einer Person, die von Schlachtplänen sehr viel Ahnung hat. Alles Mögliche haben wir ein bisschen in den Links gesammelt. Ich denke insgesamt mal von allem Lachen und Scherzen abgesehen, zeigt das einfach wirklich.
Dass da einfach noch eine Menge Aufklärungsarbeit zu leisten ist und dass sich vor allem auch die Parteien, generell gar nicht mehr nur die CDU, wirklich ernsthaft darüber Gedanken machen, mit was für Menschen sie sich in dieser Debatte eigentlich auch präsentieren wollen. Also ich meine, das ist doch klar. Ich meine, er ruft hier den Kulturkampf aus. Und ich meine, wenn das auf der Ebene stattfindet, das können sie nur verlieren. Weil, ja, also da, was soll ich da noch groß erläutern? Also das ist einfach nur zu verlieren, weil wir einfach in der Realität des Internets sind. Punkt. Ja, aber es geht halt nicht mehr weg. Wie gesagt, ich kriege jetzt diesen Gaddafi mit dem Regenschirm echt nicht mehr aus dem Kopf. Ich will jetzt hier nicht ihn auf so ein Diktatorenlevel machen und auch diese ganzen Hitler-Vergleiche. Okay, ich meine, das ist absehbar, dass das Netz sowas natürlich schnell hervorbringt. Und auch das werden natürlich gleich wieder viele nicht verstehen und dann den Godwin ausgraben und sagen, hier Hitler-Vergleiche. Und das zeigt doch nur, auf was für ein Geisteskind ihr seid.
Aber der hat ja um einen Hitler-Vergleich gebettelt. Der wollte den doch. Hättest du doch hingestellt und gesagt, bitte parodiert mich.
Das kann man jetzt so sehen. Ich will nur sagen, wenn man das alles mal abzieht, bleibt einfach noch genug übrig. So geht es einfach nicht. So kann man nicht diskutieren. Wenn das jetzt hier wirklich die Basis ist, auf der das Ding jetzt ausgefochten werden soll und jetzt hier wirklich solche Kulturkampf-Rhetorik an Start kommt mit Geschichtsklitterung, ich meine Freiheit, Demokratie und Eigentum. Hallo, geht es noch? Ich habe da mal einen schönen Podcast zugemacht zum Thema Urheberrecht, wo es schön erläutert wird, wo das mit diesem Eigentum alles so herkommt von Matthias Spielkamp. Und so will ich jetzt hier an dieser Stelle gar nicht alles zusammenfassen, aber das könnte sich Herr Heveling sicherlich auch mal anhören. Und niemand sagt, dass das eine einfach zu lösende Geschichte ist. Man sieht ja auch in dieser ganzen Debatte, wie sehr auch alle anderen da herum eiern und dass eigentlich, sagen wir mal so, der gordische Knoten im Bereich Urheberrecht sicherlich noch nicht durchgeschlagen ist. Nur, man muss halt sich zumindest jetzt mal langsam einig sein, dass es da ein Problem gibt und dass es einfach nicht mit einer weiteren Verschärfung weitergehen kann. Weil das wird uns einfach alles ins Elend führen.
Womit wir beim nächsten Thema werden.
Genau, mindestens führt es uns ins nächste Thema. Eins, was wir seit langer Zeit hier schon verdrängt haben. Und auch uns fällt das jetzt eigentlich genauso auf die Füße, wie man so den Eindruck hat, dass es allen, zumindest in Deutschland, gerade auf die Füße fällt, während in anderen Ländern schon brennende Fackeln durch die Straßen getragen werden. Wundern sich hier eigentlich immer noch alle, dass dieser Geist noch nicht weg ist, weil man sich die ganze Zeit weg gewünscht hat und das hat ja sonst immer ganz gut funktioniert.
Es geht um ACTA. Also ACTA, dieses Abkommen, was wir jetzt so andauernd schon mal erwähnt haben und gesagt haben, da müssen wir uns mal darum kümmern. Und ich habe mich in der letzten Woche darum bemüht, Sendungsgäste zu dem Thema zu bekommen, die mich aber leider zum wiederholten Male haben hängen lassen. Deswegen muss ich es jetzt selber aufarbeiten, was ich an dieser Stelle anprange. 26. Januar, heute ist der 31. Januar, wir sollen ja immer das Datum sagen, heute ist der 31. Januar, und am 26. Januar wurde in Tokio ACTA unterschrieben. Das ist ein Handelsabkommen und unterschrieben haben jetzt irgendwie die EU, Österreich, Belgien, Bulgarien, Tschechische Republik und so weiter, Portugal, Slovenien, Spanien, Schweden, also eine ganze Menge Länder, die es in Tokio unterschrieben haben. Bereits im Oktober 2011 hatten irgendwie Kanada, Japan, Südkorea, Marokko, Neuseeland und die USA irgendwie unterschrieben. Und man fragt sich jetzt, warum haben die das überhaupt unterschrieben, weil bevor das in Kraft treten kann, muss das ohnehin nochmal von, also für Europa jetzt, vom Europaparlament und den nationalen Parlamenten gebilligt werden. Das wäre dann irgendwann im Sommer der Fall. Also ich frage mich jetzt ohnehin, warum die ja überhaupt irgendwas unterschreiben, bevor das schon, bevor es überhaupt gebilligt wurde. Aber so sei es. Kurz nachdem dieses, dieses Abkommen unterschrieben wurde, trat dann der Herr Kader Arif, der nämlich der Berichterstatter im Handelsausschuss des Europaparlaments war, aus Protest zurück und kritisierte, dass es keine Einbindung der Zivilgesellschaft bei diesem Abkommen gibt, eine fehlende Transparenz seit Beginn der Verhandlungen und dass die Unterschrift ohne eine weitere Erklärung geleistet wurde, die mehrfach geäußerten Bedenken des Europaparlaments irgendwie weggewischt wurden. Damit hat es also begründet, der ist von den französischen Sozialisten. Und der Handelsausschuss, für den er leider Berichterstatter war, war eben wesentlich an diesen ACTA-Verhandlungen beteiligt. So, was ist jetzt dieses ACTA? Also, die Staaten setzen sich da irgendwie hin und sagen, wir machen jetzt mal ein Handelsabkommen, das den Umgang mit Produktkopien, Produktfälschung und Raubkopien vereinheitlichen soll. Also wir wollen irgendwie für uns regeln, wie wir solchen Sachen begegnen wollen. Also, was weiß ich, den Umgang mit digitalen Gütern, wenn die kopiert oder gestohlen werden, Generika, Marken, Kleidung und so weiter.
Und uns in dem Zusammenhang ist alle Staaten, die das unterschreiben. Und wer soll das am Ende alles unterschrieben haben?
Eigentlich schön für die wärs ja gewesen, wenn so Länder wie China und Indien das unterschrieben hätten. Aber die haben ja von vornherein gesagt, machen wir nicht. Brasilien war glaube ich auch dabei. Was steht da jetzt also drin? Sie sagen dann, dass sie anerkennen, dass es ein Problem gibt und dass irgendwie das geistige Eigentum, und da kommt jetzt auch ein bisschen der Kreis zu Heveling, ein wichtiger Pfeiler unserer Gesellschaft ist. Und dass wir das beschützen müssen, wenn wir Wachstum usw. erhalten wollen. Und dass deswegen dagegen auf internationaler Ebene gegen die Verletzungen von geistigen Eigentumsrechten vorgegangen werden muss. Und dass sie also eine Kooperation zwischen Rechtehaltern und Dienstanbietern haben wollen usw. Ich gehe das jetzt mal so ein bisschen meinen Notizen entlang durch. Ich glaube der Punkt, den man sich merken muss, ist so, es ist ein Abkommen, was den Kampf oder die gesetzliche Durchsetzungskraft von geistigem Eigentum international stärken soll. Und die Hauptsorge, die jetzt dieses Abkommen betrifft von Seiten der Kritiker, ist, dass darin so Regeln vorgesehen werden wie eine Providerhaftung. Also, dass ein Diensteanbieter im Internet, ein Provider, dafür haften soll oder in die Rechenschaft gezogen werden soll, welche Inhalte von anderen Leuten dort eingestellt werden. Also stellen wir uns irgendwie...
Telekom.
Ja, oder stellen wir uns, was könnte man... Sagen wir mal, ich betreibe irgendwie einen Blog bei wordpress.com und...
Also Provider heißt jetzt nicht ISP, sondern Provider heißt generell...
Würde dann auch irgendwann die Provider betreffen, aber ich würde mal jetzt, weil es ein leuchtenderes Beispiel ist, nehmen wir Facebook. Ich stelle bei mir auf meine Facebook-Seite, die ich nicht habe, irgendwie ein Foto von einem Bild online, wodurch ich irgendwelche Rechte verletze. Dann soll Facebook dafür in der Verantwortung sein, das zu verhindern. Im Moment ist das so, wenn so etwas geschieht, dass die dann nach einer Nachricht das offline nehmen sollen, müssen, nach deutschem Gesetz, sobald man in so einem Forum von illegalen Inhalten Kenntnis erlangt, dann muss man das sofort rausnehmen. Man ist aber nicht dazu verpflichtet, das aktiv zu monitorieren, dass so etwas passiert. Wenn man jetzt eine Providerhaftung einführt, dann muss Facebook oder welcher auch immer Inhalteanbieter das nämlich aktiv machen, weil er ja sonst selber dafür haftet. Das heißt, dadurch, dass ich Facebook dafür verantwortlich mache, solche Inhalte nicht bereitstellen zu dürfen, zwinge ich Facebook dazu, eine Infrastruktur einzubauen, um so etwas zu kontrollieren und möglichst schnell offline zu nehmen. Facebook ist jetzt wieder nicht so das perfekte Beispiel. Es geht einfach nur um das Prinzip, ich betreibe eine Plattform, kann jemand etwas reinstellen?
Warum ist das kein sehr nachvollziehbar aus Beispiel? Das finde ich schon, weil ich meine... Ich fühle mich nur so komisch, Facebook immer als Beispiel zu nehmen.
Ja, aber das verstehen halt viele.
Ja, aber da stellen auch die meisten Leute irgendwas rein. Und ich meine, letzten Endes würde das ja bedeuten, dass man quasi diese polizeiliche Tätigkeit des Überprüfens von Vergehen quasi an so einem Privatunternehmen macht. Und da eigentlich jeder irgendwie irgendwas providet und User hat. Also nicht jeder, aber viele. Würde es ja bedeuten, dass quasi alle auf einmal sich mit Urheberrecht befassen müssen. Und vor allem, woher willst du denn wissen, ob irgendein Bild irgendwas verletzt?
Genau, und da kommt jetzt natürlich die Frage, wenn Facebook selber irgendwie zur Haftung herangezogen werden könnte oder diese Verantwortung hat, dann wären sie natürlich eher motiviert, ihre Schwellen so zu setzen, dass sie viele falsch Positive haben, als dass sie viele falsch Negative haben. Weil die falsch Negativen könnten ihnen ja Probleme bereiten. Also falsch positiv heißt, ich halte etwas für urheberrechtlich relevant und sperre es, obwohl es nicht urheberrechtlich relevant ist. Alternative, das falsche Negative ist, etwas ist urheberrechtlich relevant und ich blockiere es nicht. Ich möchte natürlich eigentlich, wenn ich selber im Boot sitze, da natürlich versuchen, möglichst wenig Ärger zu haben.
Mit der Regelung würde das quasi bedeuten, dass viele Leute einfach vergeblich versuchen würden, irgendwas zu veröffentlichen, was vollkommen legal wäre, aber weil es eben nicht als legal erachtet wird oder zumindest eine gewisse Restwahrscheinlichkeit besteht, die unter einem bestimmten oder über einem bestimmten Threshold liegt, dann sagen die einfach nö oder muss jetzt erstmal geprüft werden oder liegt in der Warteschlange oder keine Ahnung oder ist mir doch egal.
Gehen wir zum Beispiel damit los, was weiß ich, ich lade meine Linux-Distribution bei Mega-Upload hoch oder biete sie per Torrent an und bei Facebook ist einfach schon mal eine Lampe, die sagt, wenn da Torrent oder Mega-Upload dran steht, dann mache ich das so.
Ich frage mich auch, wie das funktionieren soll. Ich meine, wie soll das funktionieren? Ich meine, da werden einfach Milliarden an Fotos hochgeladen auf Facebook. Da fotografieren alle ihre Kinder im Disneyland und nur weil da jetzt Mickey-Maus im Hintergrund zu sehen ist, ist das auf einmal dann wieder verboten oder was? Also das kann es ja wohl nicht sein.
Nee, wichtiger Punkt bei dieser Sache ist, wenn die jetzt das selber machen, um das Ausmaß mal zu vergleichen, also in dem Fall wäre der Provider quasi gezwungen, Polizei und Richter gleichzeitig zu sein, ohne dass irgendwo jemals ein Richter mit beschäftigt ist, oder aber eben angeklagter im anderen Fall. Also größeres Problem an der Stelle, was also solche Netzfreiheitssachen angeht. Aber das ist noch nicht alles. Das nächste große Thema, und da kriegt ACTA nochmal eine ganz andere Dimension als irgendwie dieses, ok, Internet, ist eine Sache. ACTA soll ja der Nachfolger des Trips-Abkommens sein. Und da habe ich mal mit dem Oliver Moldenhauer von Erzsohne Grenzen einen wunderschönen Podcast aufgenommen für netzpolitik.org, bei dem ich das Aufnahmegerät falsch bedient habe, der deshalb nie veröffentlicht wurde, weil die Aufnahme kaputt war. Und da geht es also darum, dass ja also der Generikahandel, also ein wirklich dünnes Eis, aber ich versuche nur mal das Prinzip darzustellen.
Zunächst einmal, Trips-Abkommen ist das über Einkommen, über handelsbezogene Aspekte der Rechte am geistigen Eigentum.
Ja. Und wie wir ja alle wissen, gibt es zum Beispiel in Südafrika und angrenzenden Ländern, wo ich auch mal mir die Lage vor Ort angeschaut habe, sehr viele Menschen, die an Aids erkrankt sind und die kriegen Medikamente. Die Medikamente, die die bekommen, sind Generika. Und diese Generika stammen aus Ländern oder werden in Ländern produziert, die in denen die geistigen Eigentumsrechte so gestaltet sind, dass Patente irgendwie früher ablaufen. Sodass quasi in Indien nicht schneller ein ein bestimmtes Medikament nachbauen darf. Ohne gegen dortiges Recht zu verstoßen. Da werden verschiedene Regeln gegeneinander ausgespielt. Unter anderem, dass Indien dann vielleicht auch Patente in anderen Ländern nicht anerkennt und so. Es ist auf jeden Fall bei diesen Kombipräparaten, also zur HIV-Behandlung, ist das eigentlich so ein Dreierpräparat. Da könnte man also diese drei Präparate getrennt von bestimmten Anbietern kaufen, dass das, was hier in Europa passiert. Und Indien liefert massenweise nach Südafrika Kombipräparate, was alles drei drin ist, zum Sechstel des Preises oder so. Da ist natürlich den Herstellern ein Dorn im Auge. Den wär's natürlich lieber, wenn sie ihre Produkte nach Afrika verkaufen würden.
Oder entsprechende Lizenzeinnahmen zumindest beziehen würden.
Genau, solche Sachen machen sie auch. Und ACTA würde an dieser Stelle jetzt dieser Praxis insofern ein Riegel versuchen vorzuschieben, in dem beim Transit Beschlagnahmen möglich werden. Das heißt, wenn Indien dann irgendwie seine Generika nach Südafrika schiffen möchte, wie gesagt, das ist jetzt alles ein Beispiel, nur ein theoretisches Beispiel, und müsste dabei irgendwie durch einen Hafen eines Landes, in dem ACTA gilt, dann würden die sich darum bemühen, das zu tun. Also versuchen quasi genau das zu verhindern. Und im Prinzip auch so, dass sie die unterzeichnenden Staaten so ein bisschen Anstrengung unternehmen wollen, die Eigentumsrechte, die in den anderen Staaten gelten, auch bei sich irgendwie durchzusetzen und denen zur Geltung zu verhelfen.
Ist alles ganz schön schwierig, die ACTA. Wir sind noch lange nicht durch. Und das prägt auch diese ganze Debatte. Und das ist wahrscheinlich auch der Grund, warum wir das jetzt hier immer wieder nach vorne geschoben haben. Weil es ist einfach so ein dickes Paket mit so viel Details, die sich natürlich über die Jahre dann auch immer wieder ein bisschen ändern. Und es wird viel behauptet über ACTA. Und was angeblich ja so der Effekt sei. Und vieles davon ist auch mangelhaft, hat sich geändert. Dementsprechend hilft man dann der Sache auch nicht unbedingt. Das macht die Sache schwierig. Aber wir versuchen noch mal zumindest hier die wichtigsten Sachen zusammenzutragen, um hier einen Start für die Diskussion zu haben.
So, und dann, was also den gesamten Prozess dieses Treffens, dieses Abkommens betrifft. Da war ja auch schon große Kritik. Du hattest das in einer vorangegangenen Folge auch schon mal so erwähnt, dass es also weitgehend unter hinter verschlossenen Türen ausgehandelt wird. Und es gibt quasi diesen Abkommenstext, der ist ein paar Mal auch geleakt. Und der ist eigentlich vollständig vage. Ja, da steht immer nur so drin, ja, wir erkennen an, dass wir uns da bemühen müssen. Und da stehen keine einzige konkrete Maßnahme wirklich drin. Also sowas wie Three Strikes, also die Überlegung, dass Internet-Provider beim mehrfachen Urheberrechtsverstößen den Leuten dann das Internet abdrehen, wie das in Frankreich Gesetz ist, aber noch nicht Praxis. Die kämpfen da ja noch einige Kämpfe, die schicken bis jetzt ja nur Verwarnungen heraus. Also, was weiß ich, ich lade urheberrechtlich relevante Datei herunter und dann kriege ich Post von meinem Provider. Und was die letztendlich dann machen wollen, ist, dass man Internet-Sperren kriegt. Also wird das Internet abgedreht, wenn man sich da nicht öfter, wenn man sich da längere Zeit nicht benimmt. Solche konkreten Maßnahmen stehen bei ACTA jetzt nicht drin. Da steht erstmal nur drin, ja, wir bemühen uns auf jeden Fall technische Lösungen zur Durchsetzung. Oder wir stimmen darin überein, dass wir technische Lösungen zur Durchsetzung von geistigen Eigentumsrechten suchen wollen. Das kann jetzt alles heißen. Und deswegen gibt es die Verhandlungsdokumente dazu, in denen nämlich genau diese wagen und unklaren Passagen konkretisiert werden sollten. Und genau die sind es, auf die auch keiner Zugriff hat.
Auf welcher Basis ist denn das eigentlich geheim gehalten? Also ich meine...
Es ist einfach nicht öffentlich.
Sagt. Also ich meine, wer handelt das aus für Deutschland? Die Regierung? Ein Vertreter der Ausschuss? Ein Ministerium? Ist das sozusagen einfach auf der Beamten-Ebene eines Außenhandelsfinanzierungen? Was wäre das hier? Ministerium für Wirtschaft? Sind die das, die das aushandeln?
Ich lese immer nur, das ist zwischen den... Also wer da aktiv am Tisch sitzt, ist mir nicht bekannt.
Okay, das müssen wir nochmal rauskramen. Finden wir noch. Ich glaube, ihr habt auch den Eindruck, ACTA wird uns jetzt hier in der nächsten Zeit noch regelmäßig...
Leider, und ich hoffe, dass wir endlich jemanden bekommen, der da ein bisschen mehr drinsteckt als ich.
Genau, da müssen wir nochmal dazu sagen, wir versuchen eigentlich fast hier schon seit Wochen zu jeder Sendung, zu den Themen-Highlights auch Ansprechpartner zu bekommen, aber bisher ist unsere Quote schlecht. Nämlich Null. Die Leute dann auch wirklich ans Telefon zu kriegen.
Weiteres Problem dabei ist, dass sie möchten, dass Provider, also jetzt rede ich von Internetprovider, also 1.1 Telekom oder so, diese Datenherausgabe machen. Also wenn, was weiß ich, klassischer Fall, Abmahnungen möchte ich geben, hab die IP-Adresse, möchte die Daten dazu haben und diese Person dann abmahnen. Also ein Nährboden für die Abmahnindustrie, die ja inzwischen durchaus schon auch öffentlich und von Gerichten kritisiert wird. Und da gibt es dann auch so schöne Fälle wie in den USA, hab ich auch verlinkt, die Homoporn-Abmahnung. Da kriegten dann die Leute, die sich irgendwie illegale homosexuellen Pornos in Torrens heruntergeladen haben, kriegten dann von so einer Abmahnkanzlei Briefe, dass sie also einen Vergleich anbieten, irgendwie 1000 oder 1500 Euro Zahlung, und dann würden sie von einer Klage absehen. Und dass sie quasi natürlich darauf abzielen, dass die Empfänger dieses Schreibens vielleicht irgendwie noch eine Familie haben oder so, und sich gerade in ihrem privaten Umfeld nicht unbedingt ein Gerichtsverfahren wegen Herunterladen von homosexuellen Pornografie aus dem Internet leisten können, und dann einfach stillschweigend die Kohle zahlen. Also solche Sachen werden dann natürlich auch durch erleichtert, wenn ich sehr einfach Anschlussinhaber, IP-Adresseninhaber herausfinden kann. Auch hier natürlich angestrebte Kooperation zwischen den privaten Unternehmen. Das heißt, die Gerichte wollen sich da größtenteils die Hände raushalten. Also es soll einfach so eine Abfrage, es soll einfach möglich sein, so hier ich bin Rechtinhaber, sag mal wer das ist, das ein bisschen entbürokratisieren, den Vorgang. Streamline. Und ja, jetzt nachdem das entschieden wurde, oder nachdem jetzt da unterschrieben wurde, haben wir in Polen, und jetzt ausgerechnet in Polen, wie du gerade schon eingangs sagtest, rennen die mit den Fackeln durch die Straße bei Nacht. Die sind richtig angepasst, die Polen.
Also es ist ein bisschen schwer einzuschätzen, welche Dimensionen die Proteste tatsächlich haben, aber ganz offensichtlich gab es zumindest in mehreren Städten, anlässlich dieser Unterzeichnung, Polens, heftige Demonstrationen. Das ist ja nun für so ein Thema nicht unbedingt zu erwarten gewesen, insbesondere weil ja so die gefühlte Aktivität der Gegenbewegung in den letzten Jahren überschaubar war. Es wurde zwar immer mal wieder so beklagt, dass das alles stattfindet, aber es war ja auch so total diffus und unklar, wann sowas kommt. Und natürlich ist natürlich der Moment der Unterzeichnung jetzt nicht unbedingt der beste Zeitpunkt, einen Protest zu starten. Aber wir wissen alle, dass es sich manchmal daran eben auch wunderbar manifestiert. Das hatten wir bei dem Zensursala-Ding genauso. Es war also wirklich der Tag, an dem die Unterschriften da gesetzt wurden mit den Providern, war eigentlich der Ausbruch des Widerstandes. Und es ist ja auch klar, dass es damit ja nicht getan ist. Solche Dinge müssen dann auch immer noch mal umgesetzt werden. Ich glaube zwar nicht, dass jetzt genauso wie in Deutschland international jetzt wohl mal ein Abkommen ausgehandelt wird, unterzeichnet wird. Und dann durch den fortwährenden Prozess wird es nie umgesetzt. Und später beschließt man nochmal die Aufhebungselm. Also das ist glaube ich auf dem Level kaum zu erwarten.
Es ist ja kein Gesetz. Das ist ja noch das... Ja, das kommt noch dazu. Vielleicht nochmal kurz konkretisieren. Die Staaten handeln da einen Vertrag aus, der für sie dann bindend sein soll. Sie machen das irgendwie hinter verschlossenen Türen. Das Begleitmaterial dazu darf nicht eingesehen werden. Also da schließt gerade, soll ich meinen, demokratisch legitimiertes Gremium, soll da letztendlich, also das Europaparlament und die nationalen Parlamente, sollen am Ende einen Geheimvertrag ohne Beteiligung der Zivilgesellschaft ausgehandelt dann irgendwie durchnägen. Mehr vor mehr Einmischen des...
Aber das Endergebnis wird dann schon veröffentlicht, oder nicht? Ich meine, der ist ja jetzt nur geheim ausgehandelt.
Der Abkommenstext, der ist ja sowieso wertlos. Also den kannst du dir ja durchlesen. Oder zumindest in den Versionen, die da, ich weiß jetzt nicht, was das aktuellste liegt da gerade ist, den kannst du dir durchlesen. Das ist vollkommen vage.
Das heißt, das ist einfach so ein Text, der nichts bedeutet und die eigentliche Wahrheit liegt in dem, unter der Hand ausgehandelten Details, die in Dokumenten sind, die keiner sieht?
Liegt in der Interpretation, ja. Also, das ist, warte mal, vielleicht klick ich mal ganz schnell hier den. Also ich schlag jetzt mal einfach eine Seite von ACTA auf. Alle Parteien sollen kriminelle Abläufe und Strafen haben für gewolltes Markenfälschen oder Copyright-Verletzung in kommerziellem Ausmaß. Das kann ja alles heißen.
Wahrscheinlich heißt es das auch.
Genau, das heißt es nämlich auch. Wenn jemand die Identifikation einer Person benötigt, um da irgendwas zu beschlagnahmen, dann sollte die die anfragende Partei nicht mehr Informationen als notwendig verlangen, um diese Person zu identifizieren, um die Beschlagnahmung zu ermöglichen.
Sollte.
Ja, also sind jetzt spontan Übersetzungen. Also wirklich ein sehr vages Abkommen, das alles und nichts heißen kann. Und die Vermutung, dass es eher alles heißt als nichts, ist da natürlich gegeben und wird natürlich auch durch diese Geheimnis-Cremerei genährt. Wenn da schon irgendwie Personen zurücktreten im Protest, dann sieht man, dass das eine richtig ernsthafte Sache ist. Weil wie gesagt, geistiges Eigentum als kleines, immer wieder schönes Streitthema im Netz, wenn irgendein Mega-Upload oder ein Kino-TO dichtmacht oder irgendein Provider Torrent sperrt, ist schon wichtig genug. Aber wenn es um Medikamente und solche Sachen geht, dann kriegt das natürlich noch mal ein ganz anderes Ausmaß. Also hier geht es nicht nur um Internet oder so. Das ist wirklich...
Aber es geht auch um Internet.
Es geht auch um Internet, ja.
So, jetzt ist die Frage, ob die brennenden Faklern es auch nach Deutschland schaffen. Es ist ja jetzt ein Aktionstag angekündigt worden.
Februar, oder?
11. Februar, oder?
Ich meine 11.
Du meinst 11. Da sind dann auch schon ein paar Demos in ein paar Städten angekündigt worden. Ich weiß jetzt nur konkret von Frankfurt, aber ich kann mir jetzt gar nicht vorstellen, dass Berlin ausgenommen ist. Weißt du sonst noch irgendwas? Gibt es da irgendwie so einen Ort?
Facebook-Seite gibt es, ne?
Wir linken da einfach mal so ein bisschen auf die bestehenden Aktivitäten. Zum Zeitpunkt der Aufnahme dieses Gesprächs hab ich den Eindruck, entwickelt sich das gerade noch. Aber ich hab so den Eindruck, man fühlte sich dann doch schon etwas berufen durch die Proteste. Es war ja auch nicht nur in Polen, es war ja auch noch in irgendwelchen anderen Ländern.
Also fällt mir gerade noch ein, in Polen gab es ja einmal die Proteste und die Oppositionspartei hat ja irgendwie mit Anonymous-Masken im Parlament gesessen.
War aber nur eine Partei, nicht die Opposition.
Ja, aber es gab dann eben so Bilder von Parlamentariern.
Das ist ein Kulturkampf, ich sag's dir.
Also noch mal zu ACTA. Man wird sehen, dass ich nach wie vor mir bei ACTA nicht so sicher bin, was ich sagen kann, was ich sagen darf. Ich habe gerade von Kiki schöne Grüße an dieser Stelle noch eine E-Mail bekommen mit den häufigsten Fehlern zu ACTA, habe die auch noch versucht durchzulesen. Deswegen habe ich jetzt da wahrscheinlich relativ viel rumgestammelt. Umso besser ist die Linksammlung mit den Leuten von edri.org, also European Digital Rights, die sitzen da als Lobby-Organisation in Brüssel und wollen sich da bemühen für das Gute. Und die haben eine schöne Sammlung zu ACTA. Bei La Quarta Turio Net gibt es eine ganze Menge, wobei jetzt wieder offensichtlich bei den Angaben von La Quarta Turio Net einige Sachen vielleicht nicht stimmen sollten. Wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstehe, wir haben auf jeden Fall eine schöne Linksammlung dazu. Und wie gesagt, ACTA, zusammengefasst sehr schwammiges Ding, scheint ein sehr großes Spiel mit dem Feuer zu sein. Und wird da irgendwie im Geheimen ausgehandelt. Es gibt eine ganze Menge Dinge, die man da allein schon an dem Verfahren kritisieren kann.
Wir werden auf jeden Fall dranbleiben an dem Thema und wir begrüßen schon mal im Vorfeld eure Kommentare und Korrekturen und Ergänzungen. Und werden versuchen, das dann vielleicht etwas eloquenter einzubringen in die nächste Sendung.
Vor allem am besten durch eine andere Person. Also freiwillige ACTA-Experten bitte E-Mail an mich. Twitter.
Twitter. Ja, Twitter macht wieder von sich reden und hat angekündigt, dass sie der Realität von Zensurbestrebungen einzelner Nationalstaaten sich gegenüber sieht. Und insbesondere, wenn man in diesen Staaten dann auch selber aktiv werden möchte, sprich eine eigene Niederlassung haben möchte und damit zumindest in gewisser Hinsicht auch unter die lokale Gesetzgebung fällt, dass man da Kompromisse eingehen muss. Und sie haben dann angekündigt in ihrem Blog mit dem schönen Titel, wie ist es noch gleich? The Tweets Still Must Flow. Wie sie denn damit umzugehen gedenken. Und natürlich gab es sofort den passenden Shitstorm von Leuten, die sich das einfach alles mal nur so im Ansatz durchgelesen haben und jetzt ist Twitter halt auch dabei und das Ende der Freiheit etc. Ganz so einfach scheint mir die Sache nicht zu sein, weil, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, gehen sie da so vor, dass sie erstens drauf, also erst mal grundsätzlich sagen, wir können nichts für die lokale Gesetzgebung. Also das ist ja auch so. Wenn du in Land X aktiv werden willst, sei es China, sei es Deutschland, wo auch nicht alles erlaubt ist in dem Sinne, dann musst du dich halt an die Gesetze halten, weil die Gesetze sind halt so wie sie sind und damit müssen sie halt irgendwie umgehen. Und unter anderem kann es eben auch bedeuten, dass sie zensieren müssen.
Nehmen wir mal, also welches Beispiel nennen sie in ihrem Text? Frankreich, Deutschland wäre pro-Nazi-Inhalt verboten. Was jetzt erst mal sachlich nicht hundertprozentig richtig ist, aber in die Richtung gehen wir mal in die Richtung. Und wenn jetzt jemand, was weiß ich, einen irgendwie Nazi-Spruch twittert, vielleicht noch mit Bezug oder sagen wir mal, den Holocaust über Twitter leugnet, dann fällt das ja tatsächlich nicht mehr unter Meinungsfreiheit. Und wenn jemand diese 140 Zeichen in einem bösartigen Ausmaß nutzt, um den Holocaust zu leugnen, dann wäre das eben in Deutschland strafrechtlich relevant. Und Twitter wäre dazu verpflichtet, das zu entfernen.
Jetzt sagen sie also, okay, es könnte dazu verpflichtet werden, das zu entfernen.
So und jetzt sagen sie, okay, wir machen diese Zensurfilter für einzelne Länder und erkennen das quasi an. Jetzt stellt sich natürlich die Frage so, okay, warum für einzelne Länder? Also warum machen sie das jetzt für einzelne Länder? Und ihre Argumentation ist, na ja, wenn jetzt also in Deutschland eine Holocaust-Leugnung verboten ist, dann kann es ja trotzdem noch der Rest der Welt hören.
Weil da ist es ja nicht verboten.
Da ist es ja nicht verboten. Und außerdem sagen sie, wir filtern nicht proaktiv. Sie kriegen ja irgendwie Millionen von Tweets pro Sekunde, können sie ja gar nicht irgendwie, sage ich mal, Blacklists machen oder so, hätten sie ja ein Problem. Sondern warten halt auf Beschwerden, quasi kontrollieren, kontrollieren das dann und sperren dann diesen Tweet. Und dann wird aber auch transparent angezeigt, was weiß ich, dieser Tweet ist in deinem Land nicht verfügbar. Das ist tatsächlich ungefähr ziemlich genau das. Dieser Tweet ist in deinem Land nicht verfügbar. Oder auch tatsächlich Tweets von Nutzer so und so sind in deinem Land nicht verfügbar. Also sie haben auch offensichtlich die vorgesehen, dass man ganze Nutzer blockieren kann. Und die Erkennung, in welchem Land ich mich befinde, wollen sie eigentlich über die IP machen. Also sie erkennen, was weiß ich, Linus hat irgendwie eine IP, fängt mit 79 an, der ist irgendwo in Deutschland. Und sagen aber dann auch, ja, und ist natürlich immer schwierig, kann ja auch sein, dass du ein Proxy benutzt und irgendwie diese Erkennung deiner Location ist natürlich nicht hundertprozentig richtig immer. Und wenn wir da einen Fehler machen, dann klickst du einfach mal bei dir im Profil das richtige Land an, weil wir können das ja immer nicht so hundertprozentig richtig feststellen. Und dann kann man, das ist quasi so das augenzwinkernde Hinweis, sich durch seine Zensur möglichst selber auszusuchen. Das heißt, dann kann ich mich für die, was weiß ich, US-Zensur entscheiden und dann kann ich auch weiterhin mir irgendwie angucken, wer den Holocaust-Offsitter leugnet.
Aber wie ist das dargestellt? Ist es dann sozusagen ein per-user-Setting, dass wenn ich jetzt irgendwie...
So habe ich das verstanden.
Ich twitter jetzt auf US-Basis.
Das betrifft dann erstmal nur deine...
Wenn ich das dann aber ändere, dann werden dann immer selektiv andere Tweets von mir ausgeblendet.
Nee, von dir selber ja nicht. Es geht ja darum, dass dir Tweets von anderen ausgeblendet werden. Also du folgst jetzt einem US-Holocaust-Leugner. Wenn das Ding da irgendwie vernünftig funktioniert, sollten seine Holocaust-Leugnungen bei dir in der Timeline immer stehen, hier, darf der nicht sagen, darf der nicht sagen, darf der nicht sagen. Wobei Twitter ja ohnehin ein Live-Medium ist und so schnell wieder die Tweets rauskommen, da hast du ja schon längst gelesen. Also bis die den Tweet irgendwann mal zensiert haben, ist der bei dir schon wieder unten aus der Timeline rausgefallen. Aber nehmen wir jetzt mal an und du möchtest weiter hören, wie du findest das ganz interessante. Da würdest du eben bei Twitter einstellen. Hör mal, hier, Twitter. Ich bin zwar gerade irgendwie in Deutschland im Urlaub, aber eigentlich bin ich ja US-Bürger und deswegen stell mal hier US ein. Und dann würdest du diese Tweets wieder lesen können. So verstehe ich jetzt die Anleitung von Peter Mühlbauer.
Ich hoffe, das baut auch jemand in YouTube mal ein.
Ja, das Spannendste wäre natürlich jetzt, den nächsten Twitter-Kline so zu machen, dass er einfach die Locations permutiert, bis er irgendwann jeden Tweet gelesen hat.
Ja, also das ist auf jeden Fall sehr interessant. Sie löschen auf jeden Fall nicht einfach Tweets, sondern markieren sie als zensiert. Und das ist wirklich... Da habe ich auch Respekt für diese Entscheidung. Das ist schon wirklich cool. Weil in gewisser Hinsicht machen sie Zensur dadurch überhaupt erst sichtbar. Es gibt ja dieses schöne Standard-Tweet oder Standard-Plakat, je nachdem welches Medium man da so wählt, so mit über Zensur. Das Schlimmste an Zensur ist... Ja, und genau diesen Effekt, dass du das dann halt in dem Moment auch wahrnimmst, hat das.
Also das auf jeden Fall. Sie machen da eine klare Transparenz. Man könnte das eigentlich auch als so eine Art sehr gutes Trollen von Zensur interpretieren. Weil wenn da irgendwie die ganze Zeit nur noch steht, das darf hier nicht getwittert werden in deinem Land, das darf nicht getwittert werden in deinem Land, dann setzt sich sicherlich irgendwann so eine ähnliche Frustration ein, wie mit, da ist dieses Video in deinem Land nicht verfügbar. Also damit kann man ja... Damit kann man, das ist ja eine Masche mit der YouTube gerade, sehr gut sich positioniert in den Verhandlungen gegen die Gamer. Also jeder, der sich mit dem Thema auseinandersetzt, ist da irgendwie tendenziell eher Anti-Gamer, während die Gamer teilweise auch Argumente vorbringt, wo man sagen könnte, okay, das Geld, was euch YouTube da bietet, scheint echt jetzt nicht so die Großzügigkeit darzustellen. Aber funktioniert auf jeden Fall sehr gut. Und sie argumentieren eben, Twitter argumentiert, wir machen jetzt weniger Zensur. Früher mussten wir weltweit löschen, heute zensieren wir es nur in den Ländern, wo es verboten ist. Das ist tatsächlich ihre Argumentation. Wir zensieren jetzt weniger. Problem natürlich ist, wenn ich, sagen wir mal, jetzt revolutionär in Syrien bin und da ist irgendwie Revolution, Twitter verboten, dann habe ich natürlich ein Problem damit, wenn ich irgendwie in Syrien agitieren möchte. Das hilft mir ja nicht, wenn ich dann die US-Bürger und Deutschen irgendwie agitieren kann, mit meiner politischen Haltung zu folgen. Also das heißt, es würde letztendlich dann doch noch wirken.
Ja gut, aber nur, wenn halt, du sagst es ja schon, es ist ein Realtime-Medium. Ich meine, das könnte ja nur wirklich funktionieren, wenn sie wirklich Filter auf irgendwas legen.
Sie haben halt in ihrem eigenen Blogpost das Medium, dass sie auch ganze Personen unsichtbar machen können. Also das ist in diesem, das ist natürlich ein bisschen, da schwächelt dann auch wieder die Argumentation, die Twitter da vorbringt.
Dieser Twitter-Account ist in deinem Land nicht verfügbar.
Dieser Twitter-Account ist in deinem Land nicht verfügbar, ja. Also username withheld, this account has been withheld in country, learn more. Also da kann man also offensichtlich auch einen ganzen username, und das wäre ja schon eine Maßnahme, die ja nur stattfinden kann und dann eben alles umfasst, was diese Person betrifft, diesen Account.
Ja, aber ich meine, es ist halt auch alles schnell. Also die Umgehbarkeit hier, die ist wirklich enorm. Ich will das jetzt gar nicht sagen, dass es jetzt irgendwie toll ist, was sie machen, oder dass es jetzt besonders scheiße ist. Es bewegt sich, glaube ich, irgendwo so in diesem Abstufungsrahmen dazwischen. Aber es ist jetzt auf jeden Fall auch nicht so, wie das am Anfang schnell wahrgenommen wurde. Dass Twitter jetzt hier so komplett zur Dark Force abgedriftet wäre. Wir hatten das Thema ja auch schon mal hier mit Twitter und Freiheit im Zusammenhang mit Wikileaks. Die scheinen da in ihrer juristischen Abteilung auch ein paar Leute am Start zu haben, die halt wirklich da ganz interessant gepolt sind und die überhaupt gar kein Interesse daran haben, Twitter zu so einem voll durchzensierten Medium zu machen. Die sehen das ganz klar auch als ihr Business-Asset an, dass sie eben genau diesen Nimbus der Freiheit an der Stelle, also Freiheit vielleicht jetzt ein bisschen, erhöht, aber einfach, dass sie dann eben doch schon ein Medium sind, über das möglichst frei kommuniziert werden kann, dass das eben auch noch gilt. Und das möchten sie auf keinen Fall verlieren. Diesen Eindruck, den gewinne ich schon.
Also man könnte diese Änderung als Ergebnis einer langen Diskussion von Menschen interpretieren, die echt keinen Bock auf Zensur haben, aber irgendwie was machen, mussten und sich gesagt haben, okay, dann machen wir es so, dass es jedes Mal dick angezeigt wird, dass wir eine Hintertür drin haben, wie man es umgehen kann, und dass die ganze Sache hier läuft und uns die Leute nicht mehr auf den Geist gehen. Dann noch machen wir nur einen ganz kurzen, würde ich sagen, ganz kurzen noch ansprechen, das Wissenschaftliche Gutachten des Max-Planck-Instituts, was jetzt öffentlich geworden ist, vor ein paar Tagen. Es wurde also in Auftrag gegeben vom Bundesjustizministerium, und die haben also das MPI für ausländisches und internationales Strafrecht beauftragt, sich detailliert damit auseinanderzusetzen, dass durch die Abschaffung der Vorratsdatenspeicherung eine Schutzlücke entstanden sei. Es wird ja immer argumentiert. Weil wir die Vorratsdatenspeicherung nicht mehr haben, gehen uns jedes Jahr so und so viele Verbrecher durch die Lappen und bleiben Straftaten unaufgeklärt. Weil wir das gerne mit der Vorratsdatenspeicherung hätten, wir die alle bekommen. Die Argumentation wird dann von Polizeigewerkschaften und natürlich auch von BKA, Herrn Zierke und so vorgetragen. Wir können das gar nicht verfolgen. Das taucht in den Statistiken alles gar nicht auf. Weil wir nicht mit Hilfe der Vorratsdatenspeicherung den Fall lösen konnten. Und das ist natürlich unter der Prämisse, dass es keine Vorratsdatenspeicherung gibt oder zumindest keinen legalen Weg, sie zum Einsatz zu bringen oder an diese Daten zu bekommen, ist es natürlich eine Behauptung, die nicht unterfütterbar ist. Weil ich kann ja genau das nicht zeigen, dass ich es mit Vorratsdatenspeicherung den Fall hätte aufklären können. Genau das kann ich ja nicht beweisen. Also wurde ja eben diese Studienauftrag gegeben, in der darum gebeten wurde, das international zu vergleichen und zu schauen, aha, Land X hat keine Vorratsdatenspeicherung, bekommt Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Wie ändern sich die Aufklärungsraten? Also gelingt es, dem Land jetzt besser aufzuklären. Oder Deutschland hat ein halbes Jahr oder was, oder wie lange Vorratsdatenspeicherung dann nicht mehr, können wir da feststellen, wie sich Aufklärungsraten verändern. Und das ist also eine 271-seitige Studie, die da durchgeführt wurde, und da wurde keinerlei nennenswerter Effekt der Vorratsdatenspeicherung auf die Aufklärungsquoten gefunden. Das heißt, jetzt steht erstmal eine Studie da, in der gesagt wird, liebe Freunde, es gibt keinen wissenschaftlichen Beleg dafür, dass Vorratsdatenspeicherung euch irgendwie bei der Verbrechensaufklärung hilft. Noch nicht einmal beim Enkeltrick. Wir kennen den Enkeltrick immer wieder beliebt. Man ruft irgendwie eine Rentnerin an, gibt sich als der verlorene Enkel aus. Die Frau sitzt seit Jahren wahrscheinlich einsam in einer kleinen Wohnung. Man geht im Nachmittag mit ihr Kaffee trinken. Die Frau freut sich, dass irgendwie der verlorene Enkel wieder da ist oder der entfernte Neffe oder der Mann. Und leider braucht man dann eben auch noch irgendwie knapp schnell mal irgendwie 10.000 Euro. Ob Oma die denn jetzt niemals schnell kurz klar machen könnte und der jetzt wirklich sehr dringt. Also relativ billiger, aber auch sehr beliebter Trick. Und fängt immer an per Telefon oder wird teilweise auch nur per Telefon durchgezogen. Bietet sich also an als krimineller Betrug, bei dem so Vorratsdatenspeicherung das erste wäre, was irgendwie interessant, was einem so in den Kopf kommt. Und selbst da ändern sich also die Aufklärungsraten in Ländern, wo es Vorratsdatenspeicherung gibt, nicht. So jetzt kann man sich natürlich weit nach vorne lehnen, wie ich das auch gemacht habe in dem Artikel. Und diese Studie hoch aufbauschen und sagen, hier, so euch, alle eure Argumente sind invalide, wir haben das mal wissenschaftlich überprüft. Problem ist natürlich, dass davon auszugehen ist, wie es auch die Wissenschaftler in dieser Studie selber sagen, dass es ihnen natürlich schwerfällt, überhaupt eine vernünftige Datenbasis zu bekommen. Und wenn wir eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung hätten, dann ist das, denke ich, relativ klar, dass sie einen Effekt auf die Aufklärungsquoten haben könnte, wenn die Daten gezielt genutzt werden. Also wenn es zur Standardpraxis wird, die Vorratsdaten zu bekommen, dann denke ich es auch relativ offenkundig, dass das auch die Aufklärungsquoten erhöhen wird. Der Punkt ist, dafür, dass das so effizient laufen würde, müsste man natürlich die rechtlichen Hürden, um an diese Daten zu kommen, sehr niedrig setzen, sodass der Zugriff sehr einfach ist.
Und damit würde natürlich auch das Missbrauchspotenzial extrem gesteigert werden.
Und dann stünde quasi eine Aufklärungsrate, ein Delta an Aufklärungsrate, ein Delta an Missbrauch, und eben diese nach wie vor unter meiner Auffassung, nach meiner Auffassung mit dem Grundgesetz, nicht in Vereinbarkeit zu bringenden Vollüberwachung anlasslos demgegenüber. Also ich denke, dass in Sachen, sag ich mal Beleg für Vorratsdatenspeicherung wirkt oder nicht, hier noch nicht das letzte Wort gesprochen ist. Wenn man sich jetzt einen Staat vorstellt, der ernsthaft so eine richtig krasse Vorratsdatenspeicherung macht, natürlich wird das einen Einfluss haben auf die Aufklärungsquoten. Wenn da wirklich mal eine Polizei hingeht, die dann richtig sagt, alles klar, jetzt gucken wir da mal richtig rein und nutzen das im großen Stil. Insofern ist es vielleicht ein bisschen, also es ist ein, so man kann das jetzt erstmal, so diese Studie ist auf jeden Fall erstmal da und Wissenschaft sollte meines Erachtens ja immer gewürdigt werden. Allerdings sollte man eben auch wahrscheinlich fürchten, dass es nicht so lange dauert, bis mal irgendwie eine andere Studie kommt.
Naja, trotzdem, es ist gerade dieses Verhältnis von, wenn wir mehr Überwachung haben, dann könnte halt mehr Kriminalität aufgeklärt werden. Da muss man sich halt wirklich fragen, ist denn Kriminalitätsaufklärung wirklich unser einziges Problem? Und ich denke, das ist eigentlich das, woran sich diese ganze Diskussion auch immer wieder entfacht. Auf der einen Seite hast du halt die Leute, die sagen, uns ist unsere Freiheit wichtiger. Kriminalität nehmen wir als Nebeneffekt in Kauf. Das heißt nicht, dass wir jetzt beliebige Kriminalität dulden wollen. Und das ist auch nicht der Punkt. Wir sind bloß der Meinung, dass eben dieses Instrument an der Stelle einfach falsch wirkt. Also einer möglichen theoretischen und vielleicht gegebenenfalls bei massiver Nutzung auch messbaren und nachvollziehbaren Steigerung einer Aufklärungsrate steht einfach ein Missbrauchspotenzial gegenüber. Ich meine, in gewisser Hinsicht ist diese Vorratsdatensprechung ja auch so so eine digitale Lederjacke, wie damals bei der Stasi, die so Blockwartstyle auch wirklich alles beobachtet und überwacht haben. Und natürlich hat man in so einer Dauerüberwachung dann nicht mehr dieselbe Kriminalität auf der Straße. Aber man hat dann eben die Kriminalität im Staat und das ist eben noch sehr viel gefährlicher. Und das loszuwerden hat genug Mühen gekostet. Von daher sehe ich das auch nach wie vor kritisch.
Also ganz klare Reaktionen sind natürlich dann hier, was ich dann sehr witzig finde hier, Jörg Zierke, Präsident des BKA, sagt dann ja. Zur Bewertung dieser Studie sagt er, dass diese Studie hätte die gefühlte Nützlichkeit der Vorratsdatenspeicherung infrage stellt. Also gefühlte Nützlichkeit.
Das ist gut, ja.
Da sitzt ein Team, ein zehnköpfiges Team von MPI-Wissenschaftlern und reißt irgendwie Daten aus der ganzen Welt zusammen und versucht sich da irgendwie wirklich eine ordentliche Untersuchung zu machen. Und dann kommt da so ein, gerade so ein, gerade er, ja, und kommt mit gefühlter Nützlichkeit und sagt, ja, und dann kommt, ist er sich nicht so schade, sogar eine, sag ich mal, methodische Kritik anzubringen und sagt, wörtlich Aufklärungsquoten als Maßstab herzunehmen, ist der gröbste Hebel, den man ansetzen kann. Und sagt weiter, die Polizei nutze auf Vorrat gespeichere Daten, um Ermittlungen zu beginnen, eine Aufklärungsquote stehe erst ganz am Ende. Das heißt, also er würde sagen, so wir haben, wenn wir jetzt eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung haben, haben wir viel mehr Verfahren und in denen dann auch sehr viel höhere Aufklärungsraten. Also nicht nur sagt er, dass die Verfahren, die wir haben, besser aufgeklärt werden sollen, wir hätten auch noch mehr davon. Also das ist schon immer sehr interessant, wie er argumentiert. Schon immer sehr interessant.
Ja natürlich, klar, weil natürlich jeder einzelne Falscharing-Vorfall auch verfolgt wird. Ich meine, wenn man überall Kameras aufbaut, dann ist halt auch wirklich jedes Überschreiten einer roten Ampel dann irgendwann verfolgt, weil das halt verboten ist. Da muss man sich halt nur fragen, ob das die Welt ist, in der wir leben wollen. Nun gut, haben wir noch was?
Ja, einen kleinen Ausblick gibt es nur. Also es droht das Thema Two Strikes am Horizont, das jetzt nun mal so als kleine Aussicht. Also ich hatte es ja gerade schon erwähnt. Three Strikes in Frankreich bedeutet, also bezeichnet eine Gesetzregelung, wo auf Urheberrechtsverstöße über das Internet, also einerseits, dass es überwacht wird und dass es dann eine Möglichkeit gibt, dass die Leute verwarnt werden. Und bei der dritten Verwarnung oder so wird ihnen dann das Internet abgedreht. Gibt es in Abwandlungen, wird es in den USA dann diskutiert mit, wir drehen das Internet nicht ab, sondern wir machen nur die Verbindung unglaublich langsam. Was natürlich sehr viel elegantere Möglichkeit ist, weil nichts mehr nervt. Also eigentlich kein Internet nervt weniger als wenig Internet.
Das ist ja die Gaddafi-Methode, so hat es Libyen auch gemacht.
Und gleichzeitig kann ich den Leuten natürlich, wenn ich ihnen noch weiter Internetversorgung gebe, kann ich die auch weiter bezahlen lassen als Provider. Dann kriege ich auf einmal Melja, einer deiner 10 Jahre lang trollen Kunden, den muss ich jetzt abknipsen. Das ist doch viel besser, wenn ich sage, cool, der kriegt nicht mehr 50 Megabit, der kriegt nur noch eins und darf trotzdem weiter bezahlen. Also gut, es gibt also verschiedene Ideen. Und Three Strikes beziffert immer solche Verfahren, wo am Ende dann irgendwie eine Manipulation bis aus der Kraftsetzung deines Internetanschlusses steht. Und Two Strikes bezeichnet dabei, meines Erachtens, von der Nomenklatur nicht besonders logisch, aber Two Strikes bezeichnet, dass man Warnhinweise bekommt. Also, dass ich dann irgendwann einen Brief kriege.
So wie es jetzt in Frankreich ist sozusagen.
Genau, und so ist es momentan in Frankreich, weil sie aus verschiedenen Gründen bis jetzt die dritte Stufe, den dritten Strike eben das abknippen, bis jetzt noch nicht implementiert haben. Und jetzt gibt es also diese 400-seitige Studie, die das Bundeswirtschaftsministerium irgendwie bald veröffentlichen möchte. Und die gebe keine eindeutige Antwort ja oder nein zu solchen Warnhinweisen. Und deswegen möchte man auf Basis der Studie nun eine zweite Untersuchung durchführen lassen. Also man macht eine Studie, die hat nicht das gewünschte Ergebnis, also braucht man eine weitere.
So lange, bis man eine passende gefunden hat.
Genau, und dann möchte man sich also jetzt die im Ausland eingesetzten Warnsysteme anschauen und den Dialog mit den Stakeholdern aufnehmen. Und da gibt es also in Frankreich die SACAM, das ist so die französische GEMA, die sagt also, ja, diese Warnhinweise haben auf jeden Fall gewirkt. Seit wir die verschicken oder seit wir dieses Gesetz haben, gibt es da eben einen Effekt, dass die Leute weniger gegen Urheberrechte verstößen oder so. Während aber die SPEDIA, das ist die Schwestergesellschaft der französischen GEMA, sagt, für die darstellenden Künstler hat Adobe überhaupt nichts gebracht, denn auch bei legalen kommerziellen Verwertungen kriegen sie kein Geld.
Unser Geschäftsmodell funktioniert eh nicht.
Und das ist, denke ich, auch wirklich, also das darf man bei diesen Sachen immer nicht vergessen. Es geht, wie gesagt, darum, es geht in der Regel nicht darum, dass da irgendwie ein kleiner Künstler zu Hause sitzt und verhungert. Es geht darum, dass Konzerne, die diese Künstler von vornherein schon an die kurze Leine nehmen, da ihre Einnahmen haben. Also es darf man, wer da irgendwie, auch wenn da mit der französischen Revolution argumentiert wird, darf man eben nicht vergessen, was momentan wir an Urheberrechtsgesetzgebung haben, begünstigt eben das Modell eines Rechteverwerters. Das heißt, ein rechter Inhaber tritt in der Regel seine Rechte ab an jemand anderen. Also der Künstler hat irgendeinen Vertrag mit einem Label oder was auch immer und dieses Label macht dann damit den Reibach. Das darf man einfach bei solchen Debatten nicht vergessen. Es geht da wirklich nicht unbedingt darum. Also diese Argumentation über den verhungernen Künstler, die ist einfach sehr grob irreführend da.
Ja, es ging gestern wieder mal schön durchs Netz, diese alte Anzeige, die geschaltet wurde gegen den Tonfilm. Als der Tonfilm eingeführt wurde so, ja hier Leute, Tonfilm, das ist ganz böse. Und da geht ja auch die Kultur. Sind wir wieder beim Kulturkampf. Da geht also die Kultur verloren und Tonfilm überhaupt, da muss man sich halt dagegen stellen. Und wenn man sich dann halt mal anschaut, wer eben diese Anzeige dann unterschrieben hat, dann sind das unter anderem die Vereinigungen der Orchester, Musiker etc., die halt einfach Angst haben um ihre alten, ja, hergebrachten Verdienstmöglichkeiten. Die Drohung von Stummfilmen. Genau, weil wenn jetzt irgendwie die Schauspieler alle selber sprechen und so, dann müssen wir endlich mal die ganze Zeit dazwischen dudeln. Und wo kommen wir denn da hin? Und dementsprechend wird da in der Richtung ein großes Fass aufgemacht. Da können wir auch nochmal drauf linken. Jaja, so ist das. Die Welt ist komplex und verlogen. Und wir sind mittendrin. Ja, vielleicht zum Abschluss noch ein paar Worte in eigener Sache. Abgesehen hier von unseren fortgesetzten Fails, Leute per Telefon dazuzuholen, die uns bei manchen Themen, wo wir uns nicht immer bis ins Letzte haben, hineinarbeiten können, da ein bisschen auszuhelfen. Es gibt andere Fortschritte und zwar auf unserer Webseite. Wer diesen Podcast über den Standardfeed hört und irgendein modernes Abspielgerät hat, wird gemerkt haben, wir haben diese Kapitelmarken drin. Das ist auch bei dieser Folge nicht anders. Diese Kapitelmarken lassen sich aber jetzt auch im Web nachvollziehen. Das heißt, wenn ihr auf unsere Show Notes geht, was ihr sowieso mal tun solltet, weil dort finden sich die ganzen Links zu den Sachen, die wir hier besprochen haben, sehr übersichtlich, weil wir verstehen ja diesen Podcast auch als Ressource, als Informationsquelle und das nicht nur als aktuelle Informationsquelle, sondern vor allem so als, wie war denn das nochmal, Informationsquelle in der Zukunft. Und wenn ihr dann zurückgeht, dann könnt ihr eben dort mit dem Audioplayer auf der Webseite auch direkt auf die Kapitelmarken draufspringen. Das heißt, wenn euch ein bestimmtes Thema interessiert, dann müsst ihr jetzt nicht mit dem Slider durch die ganze Sendung durchscrollen und mal gucken, wo denn das jetzt eigentlich war, sondern ihr könnt euch diesen Bereich direkt angucken. Da gibt es noch ein paar kleinere technische Details, die vielleicht nicht ganz so gut funktionieren. Das ist noch so ein bisschen Beta, aber das kriegen wir schon mal hin. Und ich finde, das passt hier ganz gut zum Programm. Ja, und jetzt haben wir wieder mal ordentlich überzogen.
Wie immer.
Wie immer, leider, aber so ist es. Aber wir haben ja irgendwie, passen noch auf eine CD.
Also, liebe Netzgemeinde, damit enden wir.
Genau.
Wer nächste Woche Montag früh Zeit hat, mein kleines ACTA-Stabelei hier nochmal zu begradigen, für die ich mich auch nochmal entschuldigen möchte. Aber das war der Grund, warum wir ACTA die ganze Zeit vor uns hergeschoben haben. Das war der Grund, warum ich immer gesagt habe, ACTA kommen wir nächstes Mal zu, kommen wir nächstes Mal zu, weil ich möchte da jemanden haben, direkt aus Brüssel, der sich damit auseinandersetzt. Also wer da nächste Woche Montag früh Zeit hat, sich mit uns über Skype zu unterhalten oder ein freies VoIP Programm eurer Wahl, würden wir uns sehr freuen.
Ja und bis dahin liebe Netzbürger, geht auf die Barrikaden und zitiert, wenn ihr jetzt zitieren wollt und lest dieses gebundene Hörbuch, dieses Hörbuch, was wir für euch gebunden haben, soll ich auch durch die Woche bringen.